salut hier sur twitter je vous ai
demandé de quoi j'allais parler
aujourd'hui et vous avez proposé une
trop fort et je me suis demandé de quoi
j'allais vous parlez bien simplement de
comment j'ai commencé le mentalisme qui
est sûrement la phrase est la question
qu'on m'a le plus poser le temps
d'installer un petit peu le matériel
parce qu'on est une équipe on fait tout
ensemble à une main c'est ma pratique
s'est bien accroché tu te sens table
c'est parti générique
je ne sais plus si je vous ai déjà dit
salut si c'est pas le cas
rth à lui mais si je dire salut ça veut
dire que j'ai déjà dit c'est dans une
ancienne vidéo je vous donnais ma
définition du mentalisme je vous invite
à cliquer ici
est-ce que je vais la remettre et je
vous conseille de la regarder parce
qu'elle est importante en fait parce que
pour moi le mental et c'est tout et ça
vient à la fois ça ne veut rien dire à
part pour celui qui utilise ce mot avec
sa définition cette vidéo semble la plus
claire de la planète depuis 321 ou 322
vidéo la question qui a été le plus
fréquemment posées ça a été quand même
comment est-ce que j'ai commencé le
mentalisme donc j'ai globalisé sur
comment j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à
toutes ces choses là quand j'étais petit
et le premier qui commente
ah bon parce que tu as grandi entre
temps je le banni de la chaîne quand
j'étais petit ma mère m'a emmené chez un
psy en fait il avait une amie qui
consulte un psy pour ses enfants et ceux
ci faisait les tests de qi les fameux
tests de quotient intellectuel donc ma
mère m'a emmené là bas faire ce test de
psy j'avais à peu près huit ans je crois
et je me souviens vraiment de ça c'était
dans un village à côté du mien lowbrow
c'est ça s'appelait et j'avais pris ça
un petit peu comme un jeu de faire ce
test là je me souviens vraiment de tous
les moments du ts terre il y avait un
test de culture générale je me suis là
qu'on me demander si je savais qu'ils
étaient in fine si je sais de quelle
origine il était si je savais pourquoi
il était connu me souviens qu'il y avait
des test de mathématiques relativement
simple aussi des tests de compréhension
sur des choses je me souviens également
d'un puzzle qui était composé aller de
cinq pièces où six pièces maximum je
sais plus ce qu'il représente et je
crois que c'était un chien mais je fais
pas tout à fait confiance à ma mémoire
là sur ce coup là et les pièces étaient
imprimées des deux côtés et donc 5 6
pièces esi et b pas saisi en fait il y
avait un problème de logique et un
moment donné quand tu faisais le puzzle
tu te rendais compte que la dernière psa
elle n'allait pas passer en fait tu mets
ton cerveau bugs et tu veux forcer quand
même alors que tu sais que non et en
fait c'est juste qu'il faut retourner
les pièces et leur faire un petit peu
différemment ça m'a beaucoup agacé parce
que je savais que j'étais en train de
perdre du temps bêtement et j'avais pris
ça comme un jeu je voulais dis donc je
voulais gagner le jeu tu vois et je me
rappelle principalement de la dernière
épreuve d'un toit jeudi épreuve au
lieu-dit artes le dernier test c'était
un alphabet donc toutes les lettres avec
un code en phase donc des symboles en
face de chaque lettre et j'avais je sais
pas trop là je vous dit peut-être une
bêtise une minute 32 minutes 2030 pour
m'imprégner un petit peu de cet alphabet
là et ensuite j'avais un texte à
traduire c'était donc un texte codé
et j'avais accès juste à côté de moi sur
ma gauche toujours au code et donc je
devais le traduire le plus rapidement
possible et ce qui s'est passé la
légende raconte parce que la légende a
peut-être un petit peu embellit la chose
mais je me suis jamais référer au code
de départ si ça se trouve je me suis
référé une ou deux fois mais pas
beaucoup en tout cas parce que
simplement j'avais mémoriser en faisant
une association d'image par lettre chose
que je faisais déjà spontanément et
c'est là que le psy a décidé de pousser
un peu plus loin sur ma mémoire et
concis on a découvert j'avais une
mémoire un petit peu facilité on va dire
cela que j'ai voulu en savoir plus sur
la mémoire et sur comment s'en servir
alors je vous parlais d'einstein ya deux
minutes
einstein disait un don non travaillées
ça fait d'une mauvaise manie et bien
c'est ça c'est ça m'a donné d'avoir ce
terrain un petit peu établi envie
d'aller chercher plus loin dans tout ce
qui était mnémotechnique visualisation
méthodes d'apprentissage et ça tombe
bien parce que c'est là où ma route
rencontre celle d'un livre je suis donc
né dans un village au nord de la
rochelle il s'appelle marc 6 à 8
kilomètres au nord et il ya un vide
greniers tous les ans et à peu près à
cette même période je sais pas trop vous
dire quand exactement
je vais au vide greniers g10 franc avec
moi et je m'achète un livre que je
trouve là bas qui coûte 10 francs il
s'appelle cours magica de robert v no je
vais vous le faire voir bande de petits
veinards tintin tintin pas pourquoi je
chante ça alors déjà il faut savoir
qu'on est au fin fond de la rochelle et
c'est un livre apparemment qui vient de
quelqu'un un parisien qui vend sa part
toujours marqué et c'est un cours pour
débutants mais à destination vraiment
très adulte de magie de prestidigitation
donc avec les anciennes planches de
dessins etc
mais il ya une section qui s'appelle je
vais vous retrouver le nom s'appelle
magnétisme spiritisme divination ait
transmission de pensée comme vous pouvez
le constater alors il n'y a pas vraiment
le mot mentalisme là dedans mais c'est
la première fois que je lis des choses
concernant soit le trucage en fait du
cerveau on peut dire les astuces qu'on
peut qu'on peut faire avec son cerveau
soit les procédés de mnémotechnique et
ça me passionne juste ça me passionne et
de là je vais commencer à m'intéresser à
toutes ces méthodes là en plus de ce que
je sais faire de la mémoire est assez
rapidement j'arrive à me procurer un
livre qui est sorti un an avant ma
naissance si ou lé principe brillant du
mental
l'histoire du mentalisme la mémoire du
futur la télépathie alors là quand on
parle de la télépathie c'est au niveau
du rendu des effets je ne crois pas
forcément la télépathie sait pas que j'y
crois ou pas d'ailleurs c'est que c'est
même pas le propos et ses deux choses
vont être un point de départ pour moi
pour attisé ma curiosité sur des livres
qui sont un centre et après spectacles
démonstrations sur des sujets plus
spécifiques sur le monde scientifique
aussi parce que même si je ne suis pas
un vulgarisateur scientifique comme on
l'entend il n'empêche que je suis très
intéressé par toutes les découvertes qui
est qu'ils soient récentes ou anciennes
et toutes les conclusions qu'on fait
chaque jour dans ces domaines là et
c'est ainsi que naissent chez moi de
vraies passions la première c'est de
faire des démonstrations de m'exprimer
devant les gens la deuxième c'est de
m'intéresser à touvre est une vraie
curiosité exacerbée sur comment on
fonctionne comment fonctionnent les
choses en général et comment fonctionne
le rapport entre les gens et là je vais
littéralement bouffer tous les bouquins
de la bibliothèque municipale et la
troisième chose je commence déjà à avoir
envie de transmettre ce que j'apprends
au fur et à mesure que je l'apprends où
les choses que je comprends que je crois
avoir compris
voilà pour cette trou story vous savez
maintenant quel est le point de départ
quelle est l'origine de tout ça mais j'y
reviendrai en fin d'année jeu j'ai une
surprise aussi pour vous à la fin de
l'année qui va compléter ce qu'on vient
de dire aujourd'hui
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère vraiment que ça vous aura plu
d'en savoir un petit peu plus de ce côté
là si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce en l'air je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai pris cet accent mais
mettez l'eau c'est important et
n'oubliez pas également de vous abonner
à la chaîne en cliquant alors attendez
en cliquant je pense par ici voilà ça
doit être à peu près par là ou en
cliquant un petit peu plus là bas
j'allais découvrir le magnifique nouveau
fonds qui a été fait par mélanie une
nouvelle personne qui m'aide en ce
moment rendez vous demain à 17 heures
ciao
tao